to stay overseas and go down to the
philippines where the son of a former
dictator is the projected winner in that
country's presidential election
ferdinand marcos jr aka bongbong appears
to have won by a wide margin if you
recognize the name it's because his
father is ousted former dictator
fernandez marcos who was known for
astounding corruption it's an election
that could have broad implications for
america's influence in that region and
our elizabeth palmer has more
the ecstatic crowds at his rallies
hinted ferdinand bongbong marcos would
win but his landslide marks not only a
victory for the candidate
but a comeback for one of asia's most
infamous political families
marcos lovers and haters crowded into
polling stations monday to cast their
ballots
after six years of populist rule by the
outgoing president rodrigo duterte
alleged to have ordered extrajudicial
killings of drug dealers there was huge
support for the current vice president
and human rights lawyer laini robredo
but she was no match for the marcos
machine which delivered a clear majority
of millions of votes
bongbong that's him on the right was a
teenager when his father ferdinand
marcos was president but after more than
a decade of epic corruption human rights
abuses and martial law filipinos rose up
in 1986 and marcos and his family fled
the country
furious mobs overran the presidential
palace famously discovering first lady
imelda marcos collection of thousands of
shoes ferdinand marcos died three years
later having embezzled billions of
dollars
fast forward to 2022. bongbong now 64
cast his vote on monday along with his
mother imelda
their pitch to the voters a marcos in
power means not corruption and abuse but
stability and security
at home they bought it abroad
not so much
marco's presidency is not likely to be
close to the united states that's
because marcos faces a contempt order
here and millions of dollars in
penalties linked to the money embezzled
by his family decades ago
but for millions of filipinos that's
ancient history
and bongbong is now their champion of
tomorrow for cbs mornings i'm elizabeth
palmer